hallo liebe zuschauer und willkommen
zurück bei einer neuen episode von
easyjet heute aus washington dc und wir
sind heute nicht alleine denn wir haben
einen ganzen workshop hier an der new
school of northern virginia hat würden
ja für uns ein workshop organisiert und
mit dabei sind verschiedene schulen
nämlich die bin fertig valley high score
geldinstitut washington
all diese schulen haben schüler und
lehrer hierhin geschickt wir machen
interviews in washington an
verschiedenen orten und reden mit
deutschen und suchen deutsche touristen
und wird sagen wir fangen wir an
los geht's wie gefällt es ihnen in
amerika es ist sehr anders aber es
gefällt mir sehr gut ich liebe es ist
die menschen sind sehr freundlich und ja
sehr schön sie ist sehr schön
es gefällt uns sehr hier ok hallo
willkommen in washington
das macht euch hier wir machen einen
urlaub sind gerade dabei
unsere reise schon fast zu beenden wir
haben heute einen ganzen tag in
washington verbracht bisher und machen
und hoffen und auf hopping von unserem
bus ok sehr gut und genießen jetzt
erstmal sowieso auch das wetter man muss
ja nicht nur immer die sehenswürdigkeit
genießen auch das wetter genießen
ich find's toll das gratis ist für die
bildung finde ich echt gut auch für die
jungen leute und amerikanischen generell
supernett also ich habe zwei sehr new
york weil ich bin nur das wochenende
hier und sehr freundlich und welche
eindrücke haben sie bisher von den
amerikanischen menschen sie sind sehr
offen und sehr freundlich ist irgendwas
passiert was ihnen überrascht hat nein
eigentlich nicht wobei sich das erste
mal ist dass wir sie dieses interview
vielleicht ja wir haben jetzt steven und
andere getroffen steven ist auch einen
easy german zuschauer kann das sein
du bist ein easyjet zuschauer genau und
ihr seid auch ein amerikanisch deutsches
pärchen ihr wohnt zusammen in washington
dc ist und der seit drei jahren wohnen
wer hier was ist denn für euch der
größte unterschied zwischen den usa und
deutschland der größte unterschied war
für uns mit mit der kleinen dass die
leute in deutschland nicht offen mit
einem reden also hier in den usa gibt es
mehr diesen smalltalk was manchmal ein
bisschen nervt aber auch nett ist wenn
dich jemand auf der straße anspricht und
sagt hallo wie gehts dann sage ich gerne
ja es geht mir gut hier
schönes wetter heute in deutschland
versucht man den leuten oftmals etwas
aus der nase zu ziehen ja dass so ein
unterschied wenigstens in berlin
was hat euch denn am meisten überrascht
gesund ernähren kindern wenn
normalerweise hat man nur junk food oder
fast food
aber es gibt schon familien die airline
sie folgt gesund und schauen auf bio
sache ich finde man kann die kulturen
gar nicht so richtig vergleichen weil
ich bin der meinung amerikaner ticken
gerade jetzt in dieser zeit vor der wahl
ein wenig anders und wir verstehen sie
auch gar nicht immer weil amerikaner
haben da ihre sicht und es ist
sicherlich auch mit trump eine
protestwahl und daher bin ich auch mal
gespannt wie das ausgehen wird und wie
viele skandale noch kurz vorher
ausgepackt werden um den anderen
herunterzureißen
was ist am komischsten in deutschland
dass das die leute im u bahn haben kurz
wird stark ansteigen
das hat mir jemand gesagt dass in den in
deutschland starren sich die leute in
der u bahn an und in amerika gucken sie
auf den boden aber ich habe noch nie
gesehen dass in deutschland man kommt
insbesondere new york in schwierigkeiten
wenn man die leute an staat und die
fühlen sich da teilweise bedrängt von
deinen blicken und machen dass die
deutschen das ist meine machen meine
schwester war in new york zu besuch und
starte
nein
schicke dame mit großen ohrringen an und
sie fühlte sich leicht beleidigt und ja
das war so gemacht von meiner schwester
und senkt so sieht wie auch nicht
beabsichtigt aber das fand sie nicht so
ok ja genau so wir sind jetzt bei der
heidelberg beim heidelberg pastry shop
einer deutschen bäckerei hier in
washington dc und werden mal schauen was
wolfgang büchner der besitzer hier
erschaffen hat vor schon sehr vielen
jahren verließen sie in die usa gezogen
ich bin in die usa gezogen um das
management hier zu lernen
wenn ich holte nur ein jahrelang in der
usa bleiben quartiert sich 1969 an
schöne zeit lang hat sich hier bin ja
wie hier ersten verkaufst du in einem
tag der wissel essen das ist eine große
frage
also es anders weiß ich nicht genau wie
viel wir verkaufen sehr viel essen was
wir haben jeden tag im durchschnitt auf
425 kunden welcher produkt der vision
deutsche ende usa das meiste ist ihr
brot als ist das meiste was die deutsche
vermitteln und wir bringen das kann sie
jetzt von deutschland zu die usa damit
die das dann hier haben
unsere nächste station ist die deutsche
botschaft hier in washington dc
dort wurden eingeladen von dr stefan
buchwald dem leiter des german
information center und wir haben ihnen
auch für euch interviewt herr buchwald
was macht eigentlich das german
information center solche deutschland
zentrum german information center ist
für zwei dinge zuständig für die
verteilung von informationen in amerika
an die ganze bevölkerung ganzen diesen
riesen land und für das image von
deutschland also mit projekten allerlei
art dass die die den eindruck das image
das die menschen von deutschland haben
zu verbessern
wie steht es denn um das image von
deutschland in den usa aktuell und wo
hätten sie es gerne
das image ist grundsätzlich sehr gut es
gibt 49 millionen amerikaner die
deutschen ursprung haben
deswegen ist es das bild von deutschland
relativ traditionell und wir versuchen
in erster linie dieses etwas altbackene
image manchmal zu modernisieren das
heißt wir wollen das moderne deutschland
repräsentieren
wir wollen zeigen was deutschland heute
ausmacht und gehen dafür mit
verschiedenen projekten auf die menschen
zu was heißt das denn ein bisschen
traditionell mehr das heißt dass die
menschen in erster linie an oktoberfest
an bier an die autos denken und an
solche dinge und wir und andy dirndls
und und brezeln und ich weiß nicht was
und wir wollen eben auch zeigen was
deutschland modernen ausmacht also eine
junge multikulturelle bevölkerung die
flüchtlinge integriert und die einfach
nicht so trocken und staubig und und
langweilig ist wie das manchmal
erscheinen könnte was können deutschen
waren amerikaner lernen
ich glaube hauptsächlich diese
lockerheit die die menschen hier so
auszahlt auszeichnet um diese diesen
humor
in deutschland manchmal immer noch fehlt
nicht so schlimm wie manche leute sagen
aber
und dann kommt dazu glaube ich dass man
dass die menschen hier sich sehr viel
besser öffentlich präsentieren können
man lernt hier schon früh in der schule
mit chantelle vor eine gruppe zu stehen
und dinge zu sagen das ist das kann in
deutschland können die menschen nicht so
gut
was können amerikaner waren deutschen
lernen
ich glaube andersrum gedacht vielleicht
manchmal etwas mehr professionalität
etwas mehr effizienz und auch der ganze
bereich der umweltfreundlichkeit viele
menschen lassen hier ihre autos im
leerlauf laufen es wird sehr viel
plastik benutzt papier becher
plastikbecher die dann sehr viel
verschwendet werden
ich glaube da da hat amerika noch etwas
aufzuholen als deutschland der jetzt
drei jahre in den usa lebt was vermissen
sie an deutschland
materiell eigentlich kaum etwas wir
haben ein super koch der macht und sogar
currywurst wir können wechseln kaufen
das ist alles nicht das problem aber ich
würde zum beispiel gerne meinen hund
überall mitnehmen können was hier nicht
was ihr gar nicht geht leider nein ich
hätte gerne straßen ohne löcher ich
hätte gerne straßen ohne tempolimit das
sind so die dinge die am die am
häufigsten auftauchen
umgekehrt wenn sie zurückkommen aus den
usa nach deutschland was werden sie denn
dann von müssen
ich glaube ich werde vor allem die
menschen diese dieser offenheit diese
diese fröhliche lockere art vermissen
aber natürlich auch sonnenschein und
blauem himmel an mehr tagen im jahr
aber es ist auch es ist auch in dem er
in der hinsicht weniger weniger
materielles als vielmehr das menschliche
in deutschland sind die menschen nicht
so locker wie viele nicht aber also
zusammen nicht jedenfalls nicht so wie
hier
es macht einfach spaß wenn man hier
locker auf menschen zugehen kann und
auch leute die man überhaupt nicht kennt
in alltäglichen situationen jemand an
von jemand angesprochen zu werden und
mit jemand locker zu reden
im aufzug in deutschland steht jeder
still da und schweigt hier reden die
leute miteinander wirkt sich das auch
letzte frage wirkt sich das auch auf
diplomatischem wege aussprechen die
botschafter untereinander auch locker
war
die botschafter weiß ich nicht die
botschaften sind an so viele protokolle
gebunden und an ihrer offiziellen
meinungen aber es vereinfacht natürlich
auch die kontakte zum beispiel zum
parlament oder zu den verschiedenen
ministerien hier weil wir weil man hier
nicht großartig schriftlich vorher
wochenlang termine anfragen muss sondern
wenn zeit ist dann kann man sich sehen
das ist zwar meistens sehr
professionellen kurz aber man kann man
kann sein gespräch führen und die punkte
machen dass es in der hinsicht schon
relativ locker
danke liebe leute das war unsere episode
aus washington dc
jetzt denkt euch nanu das ist doch nicht
washington
stimmt denn wir haben die abmoderation
vergessen in washington und es erst eine
woche später gemerkt mittlerweile sind
wir im monument valley
hier starten wir unsere episode für
nächste woche da geht es nämlich um
unseren roadtrip und um das thema
unterschiede zwischen usa und
deutschland und ja danke fürs zuschauen
und wenn ihr die semmeln markt und uns
jede frau guckt dann solltet ihr
unbedingt ein petzschner in von easy
german werden
das heißt ihr könnt uns unterstützen mit
einem dollar pro video und dafür bekommt
ihr viele extras das ganze ist ganz
einfach guckt einfach mal auf bachelor
unser projekt finanziert sich
mittlerweile zur hälfte aus spenden und
wir freuen uns sehr darüber
bitte werde mitglied bei uns den link
findet ihr hier unten
danke fürs zuschauen und schaut
unbedingt nächste woche wieder rein mit
unserem roadmovie